So now, we have this confidence interval and that ranges from about 38 to 42.
So, it's a lot smaller than the one we had calculated when we were basing it off
of a sample of size 35. Bigger samples give us more precise estimates by giving
us smaller intervals because they shrink the standard deviation of this sampling
distribution. So, they shrink the interval in which a sample mean might feasibly
lie. Now, notice that this confidence interval doesn't even contain the original
population mean 37.72. Therefore, it's very unlikely that a random sample of
size 250 with a mean of 40 could have been selected by chance. This is evidence
for treatment effect. So, with a bigger sample size, we have a smaller interval
for which we're pretty sure the true population lies. So, with a 95% confidence
interval with the sample sizes being 35, we had a pretty big interval. But with
a 95% confidence interval with sample sizes being 250, we had a much smaller
confidence interval. The greater our sample size, the smaller our confidence
interval for the true population perameter after the intervention. And the
better we are able to estimate our population parameters.